bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
titre en images de cette édition Vincent
Jacquet le directeur technique national
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
dresse pour nous le bilan des mondures
de Cali nous livrent déjà les ambitions
pour les JO de Rio en 2016 plus de 1200
rameurs s'était donné rendez-vous au
régate de Versailles pour tenter de
s'imposer dans l'une des 15 courses
d'aviron proposé dont le membre de
l'équipe de France Thomas Barrau
compte-rendu à suivre ils sont huit
coureurs complètement amateurs et
s'apprête à réaliser un rêve participé à
leur premier marathon lors du marathon
justement de Rome le dimanche 23 mars
immersion dans la préparation d'une
bande de copains évidemment fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end
et on passe tout de suite au cyclisme
je le vous le disais dans les titres le
DTN le directeur technique national de
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
Vincent Jacquet nous a accordé une
interview exclusive pour revenir sur les
Mondiaux de calice de cyclisme sur piste
ou les Français ont décroché 5 médailles
dont trois en or grâce aux nouvelles
lignes François Pervis Vincent bonjour
bonjour à vous j'imagine que un peu plus
de 10 jours après c'est mondiaux à Cali
sur piste le directeur technique
national que vous êtes et très satisfait
après ce bilan de médaille et de titres
grande satisfaction et on peut le moins
avec quatre médailles d'or et les
médailles de bronze pour l'équipe de
France sprint par équipe c'est un bilan
sportif tout à fait satisfaisant qui
place les équipes de France à la place
numéro 2 derrière l'Allemagne au niveau
de l'échiquier mondial donc sportivement
parlant de très beaux résultats
évidemment on ne peut pas parler des
Mondiaux de calice sans parler de
François Perlis le nouvel ini Montin qui
a qui tout simplement dans la légende du
cyclisme sur piste vous avez raison je
crois qu'aujourd'hui François
il partait pour trois médailles d'or il
a il a eu ces trois médailles d'or c'est
en soi un grand exploit un exploit par
rapport à un athlète complet
physiquement mais mentalement parlant
ils disent qu'il fait et il fait ce
qu'il dit donc aujourd'hui c'est une
grande satisfaction c'est c'est une base
solide et François n'est pas n'est pas
arrivé par là par hasard c'est la somme
de Dany d'année de travail qui
aujourd'hui a fait exploser le talent
d'un super batelet après c'est deux
records du monde qu'on a connu et vécu
en 2013 c'est vrai que c'était une belle
revanche peut-être après ça non
sélection pour les JO de 2012 il s'est
reconstruit mentalement et puis
maintenant il est devenu le leader
incontesté je crois que il l'a jamais
pris comme une revanche parce que
François est quelqu'un de valeureux et
d'honnête il a pris comme un nouveau
challenge et dès lors que l'épisode
douloureux de Londres c'est imposé à lui
il avait déjà un coup d'avance il s'est
dit je vais profiter de la difficulté
des Jeux de Londres pour me reconstruire
pour me construire et encore être plus
fort il a une petite surprise dans ces
Mondiaux de calice et Thomas bouda qui
s'impose sur le mien mais on en parlait
pas beaucoup avant de lui quand même
pour nous c'est pas vraiment une
surprise c'est une vraie confirmation
Thomas avait besoin de croire en ses
capacités d'avoir un déclic mental il a
eu lors de ces championnats du monde les
phases de Coupe du Monde qui sont
passées les mois précédents ont été des
révélateurs pour lui il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui il s'est positionné dans
le dans la situation du leader et le
déclic s'est opéré à au championnats du
monde à Cali c'est un jeune plein de
culots et aujourd'hui son talent a
vraiment explosé sur ces Mondiaux il y
avait aussi l'équipe féminine qui est
jeune on sait que c'est une jeune
génération quel est votre avis sur leur
performances de son Hitler Virginie CUF
notamment alors on a deux athlètes à
part entière qui qui ont deux profils
complètement différents je pense que
Virginie doit croire en ses capacités
réellement il faut qu'elle ait le déclic
ce qui a eu Thomas Bouddha il faut que
Virginie passe par là sandy est une
bosseuse sandy est une besogneuse elle
va avancer elle va arriver je dois quand
même souligner que même si elle ne font
pas podium même si elle ne ramène pas de
médaille elles sont quand même dans leur
meilleur temps des disciplines sur
lesquelles elles se sont engagées donc
le travail avant paye et aujourd'hui
elles évoluent l'apprentissage est long
mais le résultat sont très bon oui pour
rappel un Sandy a fini de dans la finale
du kering et puis Virginie QF 1/8 de
finale en vitesse c'est une jeune
génération qui continue de progresser et
qui va sûrement progresser encore plus
ici ouais je crois que l'outil
aujourd'hui c'est indéniable va aller
faire évoluer vers le mieux vers le plus
et il faut que nous avec avec le staff
le coach est l'ensemble des personnes
qui accompagnent ce collectif qui soit
féminin ou masculins qu'on soit capable
de pouvoir les accompagner à vraiment
performer et croire en leur capacité à
leur chance après c'est mondiaux
évidemment on peut on ne peut que louer
ces résultats est-ce que il y a une
cohésion il y a une situation qui est en
train de se créer au sein de ce Team
France de cette équipe de France alors
ça c'est tout mon c'est tout mon job
aujourd'hui on a des résultats mais
l'état d'esprit n'est encore pas il faut
qu'on crée cette équipe on a de fortes
individualités on a des gros égaux à
gérer on a affaire digérer aussi un
épisode de dont on n'a pas parlé on en a
parlé pour François pour s'annoncer
l'action mais pour l'équipe de France
sprint par équipe Baugé d'Almeida sirop
on a encore à faire digérer cette
médaille d'argent aujourd'hui on a fait
évoluer aussi ces individualités pour
que lors des grandes compétitions
internationales on arrive avec un groupe
France et non pas des noms au sein de
l'équipe de France vous le disiez il y a
ce bel outil derrière nous qui est le
vélodrome de 50 ans en Yvelines ça fait
deux mois et demi à peu près que vous
êtes installés ici est-ce que vous
sentez déjà un changement dans le
quotidien dans le travail dans la façon
d'évoluer alors le DTN oui les athlètes
oui évidemment mais c'est pas parce
qu'on a l'outil qu'on va être performant
aujourd'hui cet outil est un moyen
de cette unité de lieu comme le moyen
principal de pouvoir accompagner ses
élites à faire des médailles alors ça
s'entend évidemment sur l'entraînement
ça s'entend sur les regroupements ça
s'entend sur des stages qui vont nous
permettre de favoriser la cohésion parce
que dans l'unité de lieu on perd pas de
temps et on va à l'essentiel vous
parliez de médailles j'en ai déjà
discuté avec François Pervis ou Grégory
Baugé évidemment ce qui trotte dans leur
tête presque quotidiennement ccjo de Rio
est-ce que c'est l'objectif ultime
maintenant nous on est dirigé vers cet
objectif là 2 ans et 5 mois donc ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui le viseur il est
sur Rio mois d'août 2016 je vais faire
une mission de reconnaissance avec avec
l'un nez collaborateur au mois de mai on
est maintenant dans les calages très
précis de où est-ce qu'on va habiter où
est-ce qu'on va vivre au plus proche des
sites on est dans la on est à déterminer
la stratégie Rio 2016
néanmoins aujourd'hui c'est ici que ça
va se passer très bien on suivra ça de
très près merci beaucoup Vincent Jacquet
de nous avoir accordé quelques minutes
et puis à très bientôt sur la piste ou
aux abords je vous en prie au plaisir
tous les deux ans le château de
Versailles accueille sur son grand canal
c'est traditionnel régate plus de 1200
rameurs c'était donné rendez-vous ce
week-end pour tenter de s'imposer dans
l'une des 15 courses proposées dont le
membre de l'équipe de France Thomas
baroque images de Jonathan villemann
200 équipages une course toutes les 4
minutes sur le grand canal chaque coup
de rame est donné sous les fenêtres du
château de Versailles un spectacle quasi
unique et c'est super c'est assez beau
en plus et esthétiquement c'est c'est
parfait pour les des jeunes ça on est
tout à fait surpris de la vitesse avec
elle il pratique leur sport et leur
motivation la plupart des compétitions
françaises d'aviron sont amicales à
l'exception des championnats et des
épreuves de sélection autant dire que
les régates permettent de s'évaluer par
rapport à la concurrence ça peut être
des bateaux préparatifs pour les
championnats de France donc les quêtes
de couple les 8 donc en effet si c'est
des bateaux clubs qui vont se retrouver
sur les championnats de France et donc
de voir un petit peu quel est le niveau
et
éventuellement changer de catégorie si
on se dit bon bah non c'est pas ça pour
nous il y a trop de niveaux ou si
vraiment il y a une compétition serrée
et intéressante motivé les rameurs pour
la suite au milieu des 1200 rameurs le
membre de l'équipe de France Thomas
Barrau qui est en lice avec assez
coéquipiers de clubs mes problèmes ils
n’ont ramé que deux fois ensemble cette
saison lors des régates Versailles ils
s'assoit dans le bateau pour le plaisir
pour prendre aussi quelques marques en
vue des championnats de France en juin
prochain c'est l'occasion de ramer
ensemble effectivement on a un nouveau
coéquipier dans ce bateau parce que
parce qu'on a fait avec ceux qui
pouvaient être présents cette année
voilà il va falloir encore chercher des
des repères cet après-midi parce que le
bassin est un peu compliqué donc ça
c'est pas gagné si son calendrier lui
permet d'être présent régate cette
saison Thomas Barrau rame surtout pour
se faire une place dans le bateau
olympique du 400 barreur poids léger
allez on ouvre notre page spéciale
handball et pour la première fois depuis
1996 les moins de 18 ans de plaisir
participent au championnat de France
après une première phase de poule plus
tôt bien maîtrisée les jeunes Plaisirois
se sont qualifiés pour la phase finale
où ils évoluent face à des clubs
professionnels et vos joueurs Alexandre
Taillefer tiennent plutôt le choc assez
bien enfin finalement ce soir à vous
bonsoir oui exactement on a une équipe
quand même relativement surprise dans ce
championnat de France on nous attendait
pas forcément à nous de qualifier en
polo donc en chopé en France on s'est
qualifié assez brillamment puisqu'on a
fini le deuxième de notre pool et
c'était les trois premiers qui devaient
qui devaient se qualifier on a tiré
malheureusement une poule très très dure
on a Dunkerque et les anciens champions
de France l'année dernière Créteil qui
sont les anciens demi-finalistes et deux
autres clubs pro Paris et
Pontault-Combault et une dernière équipe
alliances Nord qui évolue principalement
à Wattrelos donc on a réussi à créer un
Expo en battant en battant Paris à la
maison il y avait une grosse ambiance et
je remercie aussi d'ailleurs tous les
jeunes qui sont venus nous supporter
lors de ce match nous a beaucoup servi
et puis on a réussi à gagner à Lens Nord
qui qui était les derniers mais c'était
pas forcément évident de les battre à
l'extérieur
donc voilà après six journées à votre
bilan un deux victoires 4 défaites pour
une découverte c'est quand même plutôt
positive dans l'ensemble bah déjà on
n'est pas dernier déjà un premier point
qui s'affiche vous êtes 4e il y a
Créteil peut-être qui est intouchable
dans dans cette bouche
par contre comme vous le dites bien on
est quatrième ça veut dire qu'en fait
les huitièmes de finale s'organise de
cette façon là il y a des huitièmes pour
les premiers deuxième des 8e pour les
trois quatre et des huitièmes pour les 5
6 et notre objectif c'est de réussir à
s'accrocher à cette quatrième place pour
l'instant on y est puisque Google avait
RH particulier on est devant Paris
donc il y aura un match très important
dans 15 jours à Paris et puis il y en a
ce week-end contre Dunkerque les
deuxièmes et et
je pense qu'on peut accrocher quelque
chose s'il y a une grosse ambiance à
domicile et ça j'en suis certain
un petit peu on peut les mettre en
difficulté
parce que sur un match tout peut se
faire pour revenir sur le week-end
précédent vous avez connu la défaite
malheureusement 34 à 24 à
Pontault-Combault plutôt logique cette
défaite non alors oui et non dans si on
se dit si on prend un peu de recul oui
mais je pense que on aurait on avait les
moyens de les accrocher le début du du
match où on trouve puisque à un quart
d'heure on est à 7,7 à 20 minutes ton
père que d'un but à 19 après
malheureusement on s'écroule un petit
peu pour partir à 5 buts à la mi-temps
je pense qu'on a un petit peu de
problème à revenir après les trêves là
c'était les matchs les matchs aller et
il y avait une très grande image retour
pareil on les avait rencontrés premier
match du championnat de France après la
première phase et pareil on avait été en
difficulté on avait pas montré notre
meilleur handball donc voilà il faut
travailler sur sur les reprises et puis
et puis continuer à bosser bosser et
chaque défaite faut en tirer des des
conclusions pour pour avancer et faire
mieux au prochain match la force peut
être de votre groupe aussi c'est que
tous ces jeunes quand j'étais venu vous
voir notamment l'entraînement cet hiver
se connaissent depuis longtemps et ils
travaillent bien ensemble c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui vous fait
progresser exactement cette saison
exactement c'est un groupe sérieux qui
travaille sérieusement l'entraînement
qui manque d'expérience mais ça ça
s'acquiert ça s'acquiert au fil des
matchs et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
toujours continuer à travailler c'est
par l'entraînement que qu'on réussit à
gagner et c'est ce qui nous a montré sur
les matchs aller on perd les premiers
matchs et puis finalement on en gagne
deux d'affilés donc voilà il faut pas
être un inquiet par rapport à ça il faut
continuer à bosser continuer à prendre
du plaisir l'entraînement en match pour
pour faire d'autres performances sur les
sur les matchs qui nous reste on a une
quatrième place à chercher qui serait
qui serait
et justement à chaque match est-ce que
les joueurs ou vous apprenez peut-être
des petits détails des petits rouages
qu'on découvre quand on découvre
vraiment le championnat de France il y a
deux choses il y a aussi moi qui
découvrent relativement le groupe
puisque je suis arrivé en début octobre
avec le groupe donc
des matchs au fil des phases passer
ensemble j'apprends à voir comment on se
comporte le groupe au gré des
difficultés le groupe aussi apprend à me
connaître je pense que c'est c'est
réciproque ensuite évidemment rencontrer
des équipes qui sont professionnelles
comme Dunkerque Créteil Paris Pontault
jouer dans leur gymnase dans l'enceinte
des pros etc c'est des expériences que
je pense sont sont plaisantes
enrichissantes bonnes à prendre pour
pour les joueurs et puis à un moment
donné ça ça dédramatise peut-être le le
fait de rencontrer une équipe pro c'est
une équipe pro ça reste une équipe de
handball complètement battable la preuve
avec Paris que vous manque-t-il
peut-être entre justement ces équipes
professionnelles comme Créteil Dunkerque
etc et puis vous qui découvrez ce
championnat de France il y a déjà le
fait que ils ont l'expérience de ce
niveau de jeu donc quand il y a
peut-être des moments des difficultés
pendant le match des périodes un peu un
peu creuses
nous on manque encore un petit peu de
d'Alan vers l'avant et vous dire c'est
pas très grave on va se rattraper sur le
reste du match il manque encore un petit
peu ça il manque un petit peu de de de
nombre de joueurs dans le groupe on a un
groupe un petit peu restreint donc on a
pas il y a pas eu de recrues cette année
donc un petit peu restreint mais qui se
bagarre avec avec César mais ça et ça
c'est très très bien voilà il nous
manque un petit peu un petit peu
d'organisation globale dans dans
l'expérience de ce de ce championnat
quoi voilà et vous le disiez donc votre
objectif pour cette fin de saison il
reste encore quatre journées c'est de
conserver cette quatrième place
c'est de conserver cette quatrième place
ça passe par une victoire contre
Wattrelos ça passe par une perf à Paris
et ça peut passer aussi par par une
paire contre Dunkerque ou contre Créteil
voilà et notamment d'un car ce week-end
je pense que chaque match est gagnable
on peut on peut toujours gratter même
les premiers très bien donc rendez-vous
vous le disiez ce samedi 22 mars donc
contre le deuxième Dunkerque à domicile
merci beaucoup Alexandre d'être
passé sur le site sport en suivra ça
évidemment de près pour voir si les
huitièmes de finale sont abordables
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup ils sont huit coureurs
complètement amateurs j'en parlais dans
les titres ils s'apprête à réaliser un
rêve participé à leur premier marathon
lors du marathon justement de Rome le
dimanche 23 mars ce dimanche immersion
dans la préparation d'une bande de
copains images de Jonathan Willmann
ils effectuent leur dernier footing
comme pour se rassurer les ultimes
foulaient avant la grande épopée sur les
routes italiennes Philippe Katy
Christine et leur partenaire se
préparent au marathon de Rome très
stressé j'ai des problèmes
non pas de sommeil mais l'intestin
j'arrive plus trois à manger donc c'est
les nœuds au niveau d'estomac mais bon
on va y arriver je ne dors plus je ne
pense qu'à ça j'ai même du mal à me
concentrer j'espère que mon patron ne
verra pas parce que j'ai du mal à me
concentrer sur mon travail je suis
concentré sur sur la performance le
trajet elle connaît cette bande de
copains depuis plusieurs années pourtant
au départ qui a dit Christine n'adhère
pas du tout au projet elle faisait
partie des accompagnants mais tout
bascule lors d'une soirée de novembre où
l'entraîneur leur présente le projet
sportif et là je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas le faire
et je me suis prise un peu au jeu
lorsque alors je suis assez challenge et
lorsque le coach a dit que sur la
population française il y avait à peu
près un peu moins de 100.000 personnes
qui avaient couru un marathon je me suis
dit il faut que j'en fasse partie le
premier marathon on cherche pas la on va
pas chercher un chrono on va surtout
chercher à le finir donc on a privilégié
un petit peu les ce qu'on appelle les
sorties longues sur des sorties d'au
moins deux heures deux heures et demie
c'est-à-dire de passer un cas
psychologique de courir longtemps avant
cela il courait tous ensemble une à deux
fois par semaine depuis plusieurs années
Gérard a donc créé un planning
personnalisé pour chacun avec des
séances de fractionnés adaptées à leurs
capacités physiques ah mais je peux plus
m'en passer c'est une drogue ah oui oui
tous les dimanches à la même heure faut
aller courir c'est oui c'est vraiment
une drogue mais pour franchir la ligne
ce peloton de coureur devra surpasser le
fameux mur des 30 km une distance qu'ils
ont accompli pour la première fois il y
a quelques semaines ça serait de le
terminer
mais voilà secrètement je me fixe 4h30
je m'étais fixé même objectif que
Philippe mais comme je cours beaucoup
moins vite que lui je me dis que c'est
peut-être un objectif un peu un peu
surréaliste donc je vais fixer 4h30 mais
on va peut-être faire 5 heures ou
4h45 peut-être au-delà du chrono le plus
beau moment sera très certainement le
passage de la ligne d'arrivée qu'ils
espèrent tous franchir le 23 mars
prochain
allez on passe au résultat du week-end
on commence une fois n'est pas coutume
par le football en Division d'Honneur ce
week-end Versailles 6e se déplaçait sur
la pelouse du deuxième Créteil
l'usitanos pour le compte de la 21e
journée et les joueurs de David Giguet
ont ramené les deux points du match nul
score final de but partout en promotion
d'honneur il y avait un match en retard
de la 15e journée dans la poule B trappe
se déplaçait à Noisy-le-Grand et c'est
imposé de A1 les Trappistes gagnent deux
places au classement et remonte à la 6e
place en rugby plaisir c'est incliné de
9 points dans le choc de cette 19e
journée de Fédérale 3 les joueurs du PRC
recevaient le leader a vaincu Orléans
ils ont dû s'incliner 16 9 plaisirs
concerts tout de même sa deuxième place
basket basket féminin plutôt 20e journée
de Nationale lune et les féminines de
l'Entente le chêne et Versailles se sont
imposés à domicile face à La Garnache 64
à 58 et surtout dans le même temps vous
le voyez leurs concurrent direct pour le
maintien Rennes c'est incliné à
Franconville grâce à ce quatrième succès
de la saison les joueuses de Stéphane
Rollet peuvent encore croire
mathématiquement au maintien avec deux
de retard sur le dixième reine chez les
hommes 20e journée de National 3 et trap
a infliger le carton de ce week-end au
Club Athlétique Lexo viens 107 à 77 et à
l'inverse malheureusement l'entente le
chêne et Versailles n'a pas existé sur
le parquet de Rouen lourdes défaites 91
à 59 Ce samedi on part en rallye vers le
Maroc ville le village départ du 24e
Rallye des Gazelles dans les jardins du
Trocadéro à Paris était donné seul
rallier red 100% féminin je vous le
rappelle et uniquement en hors-piste
composé cette année de 160 et qui page
les gazelles devront parcourir 6 étapes
en huit jours sans aucune connexion web
avec l'extérieur les deux Yvelines que
nous suivons Christelle et Sophie
veulent jouer une place au classement
général dans leur crossover elles
emportent évidemment leur nourriture
pour toute la durée du rallye mais aussi
de quoi se dépanner dans le désert les
plaques de désenchablage et leur
matériel de navigation
on a fait les contrôles techniques hier
à Dreux tout s'est bien passé le
matériel est ok les vaccins tout est ok
les carnets de vaccination donc sereine
il y a plus qu'à j'ai très bien dormi
aujourd'hui c'est que du bonheur donc
pas de problème tout était prêt la
voiture
ma pilote ma copilote on est tout prête
donc on a très bien dormi ouais et pour
ces derniers moments de répit évidemment
leurs proches étaient tout près de leur
crossover pour les soutenir jusqu'au
bout on les écoute on a commencé à les
soutenir à partir du début de leur
projet qui a démarré il y a à peu près
une année et demie donc aujourd'hui
c'est juste le départ et puis maintenant
c'est elle de s'éclater pour les trois
semaines qui sont qui sont devant elle
faut être sur le podium il y a les Jeux
Olympiques qui sont passés par là et on
a des notions de réussite et de
médailles donc voilà on espère que c'est
déjà une belle aventure quoi qu'il en
soit mais faire un résultat serait
toujours plus satisfaisant
envolé beau le 11ème journée de régional
lune et Montigny c'est incliné dans le
derby yvelinois face au leader
Sartrouville 3.7 à 0 après une
malheureusement une belle résistance
dans la première manche perds du 26 24
et score identique pour plaisir
Villepreux face à orsèche Chevry les
deux clubs sont respectivement 6e et
deuxième de leur poule en tennis de
table quatrième journée de match Paris
de national une féminine et autant de
défaites pour l'Entente voisins
Saint-Arnoult qui s'est lourdement
incliné à domicile 8 matchs à zéro face
à Bordeaux foutus troisième journée du
championnat de français l'idée et après
15 matchs sans 15 jours pas non sans
match le championnat de France donc
reprenez ses droits pour la troisième
journée trois matchs et trois victoires
pour les Templiers les joueurs
d'Emmanuel Charret recevaient au
complexe sportif d'Élancourt les
centurions de Nîmes et les Templiers
vont ouvrir le score par leur quater bac
américain sunshelton ils ajouteront par
la suite trois autres touchdown par
Nicolas Ekman et Pradel score final 28 à
0 sans avoir il faut le dire
véritablement briller et l'en cours bas
des ni moi valeureux mais limitée en
attaque les Templiers restent donc
invaincus sur cette saison avant
d'affronter les dauphins de Nice ce
week-end une dernière information avant
de nous quitter vous pouvez désormais
vous inscrire à la cinquième ronde des
butineuse avec cette année un nouveau
parcours un trail de 26 km départ prévu
le 13 avril prochain c'est la fin de ce
7 8 sport merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain même heure